Come on, come on
gimme a litte more
Whoo!
Just another Tuesday,
training a smoking hottie.
Man, I love being
a personal trainer.
- Hey, big stud,
put your camera away
so you can focus on me.
She stares at Sammy's
rippling muscles, as lust--
- What?
Cut, cut, cut!
You don't read
the stage directions, you moron.
All right, we're filming
for real this time.
No more screw ups.
[beeps]
You know what's crazy
about this job?
I mean, you're a smoking hot--
[door opens]
oh!
- Oh!
[gagging]
Oh, oh!
- Jeff, are you okay?
- Damn it, you guys
get away from me!
Today has been a nightmare.
I couldn't even
get a courtesy laugh.
Every single person out there
is just a uptight asshole!
- Sounds like you're not
respecting your audience, Jeff.
- [sobbing]
My dad's gonna die.
It's all because
I'm the least funny,
stupidest, loseriest guy
in the world.
- Guys!
[uplifting piano music]
- [gagging]
- They love you, Jeff.
- They do?
♪ ♪